well we were standing there with the
photos of our loved ones this is my
brother Mark Herring he was 54 when he
died on the 19th of March 2020 and he
Hancock approached us
and I weren't having any of it I was
like no don't don't you even think about
it and I turned my back on him
and he was looking for forgiveness
but I said forever he'll be forever
looking because you're not going to get
it off
you'll be forever looking for
forgiveness because you're not going to
get it off the bereaved
what did he say to you
he didn't even get a chance to say
anything to me I just turned my back on
you because he is absolutely disgraceful
our loved ones died on his watch
and he is accountable and should be held
accountable for all the deaths
he travels he's trying to stop you start
by saying sorry yes it seems that way
that he was trying to apologize but I
told him don't even go there